Hello again, this is Dr. Kevin Connors, I just wanted to address some questions that we
get frequently from patients or perspective patients on programming their
rife and what the frequencies mean when we look at a person's program. So remember
when we're using rife technology we're using frequencies. So I always say
the quality of rife technology has to do with a few factors. What is the
quality of the machine? Does it actually put out enough power that the
frequencies are going to effectively make changes to your cells and help your
body be able to overcome whatever disorder you're dealing with. So you have to have
a powerful enough machine. Typically those handheld machines, the ones you can put
your pocket and stuff, they're not powerful enough to make any changes in your
body. Your very little changes in your body. Secondly my opinion is you have to use
light frequencies especially when you're dealing with cancer or something like that.
You need light frequencies so it has to have a Tesla tube bulb. We are using the
true rife. We use other rifes as well but this is a picture of a true rife
drawn by my daughter, a great artist. So the question, how do I know what
programs I'm running, what frequencies I'm running for my cancer. Let's clear
up one erroneous thought that people have. Many people think that they have that
there's one frequency for a cancer. Like I've got pancreatic cancer. What's the
frequency I should be running? That is not true. There's there are hundreds
sometimes thousands of frequencies that are known to affect a specific
cancer. So when we program a rife for somebody with pancreatic cancer, we're
using all the known frequencies that can benefit somebody with pancreatic cancer.
And there's at least hundreds of them. So there isn't a specific frequency that's
going to destroy a cancer. That is that is misinformation. And so clear that out
of your head. We're trying to use frequencies to effectively get your immune
system to be attracted to that cancer to be able to get your immune system to
do its work and kill the cancer. The rife is destroying things. The rife is
stimulating your immune system to do what it can do. So you also need to stimulate
your immune system with nutraceuticals, with diet, with a good attitude. All these
things play a part. The rife is not a miracle one magic tube that's going to
solve all your problems. But without the rife dealing with cancer, I think it
makes it much more difficult. So using a rife for cancer patients can be
miraculous, but you got to keep it perspective. So when a person looks at their
program that we created. So here's a screenshot of a program. You see this
little box. This is in the true rife program itself. You see this little box
that has all this fuzz, pulse, dwell, duty. And then after duty, it says 45 and then
underneath duty 45, it says these numbers. These are the frequencies that are being
run. The other thing is the fuzz, the pulse, have to do with the background
frequency. And then the main treatment frequency or therapeutic frequency is
under that duty. In this case, it's multiple frequencies. 595 hertz, 844 hertz,
848 hertz, and so on. There are multiple frequencies under each of these duty
cycles in everyone's programs. When we program somebody's rife, we're
programming eight to nine hours overnight programs. You could run some of the
other programs that are already in your rife machine that might be only 10 minutes
or an hour long. And they're going to be probably less frequencies and much lower
dwell. How many seconds it's going to be on each one of the frequencies. So we're
not programming just one frequency. There's not just one frequency for a specific
disorder. There's multiple known frequencies for the disorder. So if you're in your
rife program and you play with this box right here, you will actually change the
program. If you actually played with it, tweaked with it, put in a different
number here, and you hit save, then you would save the program, and you could
effectively cause the program to run. Because it won't run certain frequencies
under different duty cycles. And if you're having an issue with your rife, that
might be the problem. You accidentally hit something and saved it. So we might have to
fix that for you. So clearing up some misunderstandings. There's not just one
frequency for a cancer or even several frequencies for a cancer. There's hundreds
of different frequencies for a cancer. And when we program a rife, we program other
frequencies in to help the person's bodies immune system and their detoxification
pathways as well. So all these things are what we're looking for. Here's an example
of just some of the frequencies for flukes. These are known frequencies that have helped
people with the parasitic fluk. So just gives you an idea of numbers of
frequencies that you're dealing with. Here's just one little sheet that I just
copied and pasted a screenshot of some frequencies that we use for a
paecreatic cancer. A lot of known frequencies there. Now understand, some of these
frequencies for paecreatic cancer may be the exact same frequencies that we might
use for colon cancer or maybe a same frequency that you might use for a migraine.
So there are frequencies that affect your cells in certain ways. So you need to
understand it's not one little specific frequency for one little disease. These are
frequencies that can be crossed. So this frequency let's say 19, 120, 1,920 might
be a frequency that can be very beneficial in 27 different maladies. So it's not
always specific to one thing, nor is there one or even several frequencies that
are only specific to one melody. Hopefully that clears it up. The second part of
that question, how do you create our program? So how we write programs for people as
number one, we put in all the known frequencies for their diagnosis. So they're
diagnosed with paecreatic cancer. There are a lot of known frequencies that can
benefit people with paecreatic cancer. So all of those frequencies are going in
that person's program, typically every night. So we program overnight programs
because we want our patients to be running the right at least at night while
they're sleeping. That fits to our philosophy that we want people to live during
the day and not to be tied down to a machine, even a good machine that's going to
help them during the day. If at all possible, we want them to be living and
fulfilling their purposes during the day. At night, you have to sleep any
home. So why don't we just get treated at night? So we write overnight programs. If
the person is less ambulatory and less out and about, then we can write day
programs as well and footpath programs and all those kind of things too. But at
least the night programs are running every night. So A, we put in all the known
frequencies that are known out there through experiments, through data, for that
specific malady. That's the first thing that we put in the person's nightly
program. Then we add frequencies through our testing. And this is really key
because we're dealing simply with frequencies. How do we know that? Okay, this
person was diagnosed with adnal carcinoma of the colon. How do we know that, you
know, liver frequencies aren't going to help him or her even more so. So we test with
the cheek swab testing. We do the testing to find out what other frequency sets
we're going to add. This is where people end up getting two weeks or three
week programs that they'll have an ABC program that they'll run on a nightly
basis because a lot of other frequencies came in through the testing. So adding
those frequencies through the testing is a key component in the success of what
we do. And then lastly, we add problem specific frequencies. So if the person
might make a comment that, hey, I've had problems with fungus my whole life. Could
you add some fungal programs to your to my overnight program? Or I'm dealing
with breast cancer, but I also have all sorts of colitis. And that is a real, you
know, life changer for me. Can you add those to my overnight program so I don't
have to spend time during the day doing all sorts of colitis programs. So we do
add problem specific frequencies as well. And there's a fourth piece I didn't
put on here, but we add other frequencies to support the body. So we'll add liver
function detoxification frequencies, kidney function frequencies, and DNA healing
frequencies to that person's program. We do that on everybody's program because
no matter what condition or diagnosis you're dealing with, you need to have
proper liver and organ function and detoxification pathways in order to heal. So when
you look at a program and you see all these numbers, these are your frequencies. If
a person ever asks us, well, what does that frequency mean? We do not answer that
question no matter how much you probe us because the frequency 609.37 doesn't
necessarily relate to Lyme disease or pancreatic cancer. It can relate to 30
different maladies. And because you test on a frequency that might say Lyme
disease does not mean you have Lyme disease or does not mean you have pancreatic
cancer. It means that frequency will be beneficial to you. And it could give
people wrong ideas because they tested positive for a frequency. And then they
think they have that disease. That is completely incorrect information. And I do
know doctors that actually will test for frequencies of the teleperson. They have
a condition because of frequency tested positive for them. That's just that's
just improper diagnosis. It's very least. It's malpractice maybe. It's just
wrong. It's not correct to say that to a person. It's misinformation. So frequency
has to do with just how your body is responding to that frequency. That it's
beneficial for your body. It benefits your body at that frequency. That's why we're
using that. It's stimulating your immune system. It's waking up your cells. It's
bringing back residents. It's bringing back healing. That's the way God made you.
So hopefully this helps with understanding frequencies just to weep it. And we'll
continue to make videos like this. Thanks.